a hundred percent of the time you were
under a state of construction and all
your body knows
is environmental stimuli now so you have
this amazing opportunity to through
exposure therapy you can start to make
yourself be stronger or weaker so if you
don't expose your body to enough
exposure in the form of heat in the form
of cold in the form of some type of
hermetic stressor then the body will
start to atrophy because it's inherently
incredibly lazy
is it there won't be a single shot where
i can put my hand in all of these will
oh
do you need to see it i thought it was
just an audio thing well no because what
you're trying to do is you're syncing
you're syncing the audio with the video
can watch it
i thought it was just an audio blip but
yeah you're right
god dang it what can i say man i'm not a
videographer no no but i just like
clapping yeah just hitting they both
clap boom all angles podcasts
podcast time yeah we're locked in
alexander welcome to the show
christopher thank you for making this
happen it's been a
goddamn pleasure getting to know you
over the last few weeks so good man yeah
yeah the bromance has happened quickly
bromance is real it's got serious yep
very fast yep we're moving quick how
would you describe your approach to
fitness i've been very interested since
i've been out here we've trained a fair
bit
we've done some sessions barefooted in
on it doing sprint training and
contralateral movements and all manner
of different things that as someone that
spent a lot of time training
i've seen online but
i've not really been exposed to very
much i'm quite interested to work out
how
you arrive at whatever view of health
and fitness it is that you have yeah
um so my
first thanks for doing this i appreciate
it uh my background
mostly was in manual therapy like my
main field of specialty is working with
people from hands-on bodywork
and before that it was it was training
but my main interest really has been
helping people come into alignment with
their bodies
so that we can get them to a point that
when they move through their lives
as they are breathing as they're just
living their lives
they can be
almost self-organizing into a greater
place of alignment of balance of
homeostasis just through their existence
and that sounds a little bit maybe like
meta and out there
so specifically what that means is
looking at what are the the variables
the environmental conditions that are
forming the body to fit into the
positions that might create
discomfort or disease
and so my approach to fitness
isn't so much about what we're doing in
a gym it's more what we're doing for all
the times that we're not in the gym and
i consider the gym to be for me the
gym's like
my buddy kelly start who he did the ford
for my my book coming up
he calls it like classical ballet you
know so when you're in the gym you're
working on these classical forms to
bring your body into
balance enough that you can go out and
do modern dance you know modern dances
the rest of your life and so what i'm
really interested with with fitness
predominantly is uh how do you start to
integrate the concepts that you'd learn
in a gym in a yoga studio
in a martial arts studio into the way
that you show up in business in you know
when you're out on a date with somebody
when you're at your house watching
netflix
all of that is fitness and your body
doesn't know the difference between i'm
in a yoga studio or i'm just you know at
my my house in my underpants what would
you say to someone that says
fitness and my training in the gym has
nothing to do with how i show up in
business fitness is for fitness and
movement is for movement why does it
matter about how i train in the gym
relates to how i show up for a date yeah
so it's like the idea of you know being
taking 20 years to be an overnight
success you know we're cultivating
we're grooving
paths you know neuro
neurological paths muscular paths
neuromuscular paths every day throughout
every moment you know so your body
doesn't know an off and on right now as
we're sitting in this position you are
generating electrical stimuli and around
your hips in any place that your body is
coming in contact with the with the
chair you know so that the term for that
is mechanotransduction
you're squishing cells you might be
shearing cells you might be twisting
cells and then there's going to be a
chemical response a chemical translation
to that and within that that pushing
that's happening against your hips
there's electrical charge around that
space it's called piezo electricity
that's going to be sending a signal to
the cells that would be building
connective tissue or bone tissue or
muscle tissue or fascia
and
what you're sending within these signals
you're you're like the engineer of your
body
you're saying okay we need to beef up in
this space around maybe you know maybe
you have bunions in your feet so you
actually can see like a callusing of
specific tissue that's just wear and
tear in that specific range of motion so
you're sending that electricity based
off of the way that you live your daily
life
and then you know the fibro blasts and
the fibro class these little cells that
either add tissue or take tissue away
they respond accordingly
and you are structuring yourself just by
sitting in a chair and so when you take
that mindset of like
holy crap like right now i'm literally
under a state of construction when you
get up off of this chair you're you're
tuned up to perform in the shape that
you've been practicing most
you know so a thing that you might have
heard is practice doesn't make perfect
practice practice makes permanent so
throughout the day you're continually
practicing how to engage or inhabit your
physical body
and then
when it does come time to show up in a
meaningful way you got to pick up a know
a heavy trailer you know or something
you know you got to suddenly sprint
across a parking lot or whatever it may
be
your body is tuned up and queued up to
be able to perform because you spent the
last
day week month year
in more of like a kind of like a ready
position
and then you can be too ready you know
where you're too queued up you're in
like sympathetic overdrive
and
that's gonna be too much if you're
adding too much stiffness into the
system then the system can't uh rest and
digest and heal and repair
you know so this isn't what i'm saying
doesn't mean you always have to have
like a stick up your ass and have like
axial extension like your spine's back
you know you look perfectly enlightened
and samadhi and spiritual and strong and
stable uh it's being able to relax but
being able to relax into functionality
the way that we can relax into
functionality uh you know there's
specific things that we can talk about
what would you say
looking at the current
trends in fitness and training
what would you say are the main areas
that people are missing out on or what
are the main problems that you're seeing
with most people's training programs
well i mean there's a lot of things it
depends it really depends on what gym
you're in
you know so if you go to a most
traditional
like a 24-hour fitness type space
there's a lot of
disintegration or myopic focus on
specific muscles without much awareness
to integrating the whole putting the
whole body together to work as as one
one integrated body
so when you're excessively focused on
myopically breaking down individual like
a muscle by muscle approach
you just can't do it like you can't
organize
640 odd muscles depends on the specific
individual you know 360 joints it's just
it's too much chaos
you know so for you to be able to
go in and really think like you know
joint by joint muscle by muscle i'm
gonna be engaging these and then i'm
gonna it's just gonna magically all come
together that can be confusing for the
body you know so what do you mean by
confusing it can be confusing for the
body in the sense that
if you don't train athleticism you won't
just
self-organize and be athletic okay so
breaking the component parts of
musculature apart yeah and training
biceps and triceps and overhead
extensions and chest press blah blah
yeah so if you're excessively
aesthetically focused it's
completely fine there's no moralistic
judgment
juji mufu is a good example of this
where he has done a a pretty good job of
integrating
athleticism and calisthenics and
gymnastics and powerlifting and
bodybuilding you know so he's a bit of
an oddity in his ability to to juggle a
lot of variables and it's really
beautiful he calls himself a hybrid
athlete right he is what he refers to
yeah that's what he is a polyethylene i
can't remember yeah you know and then
within within that
i would say you know athletics goes
beyond just you know
musculoskeletal
integration but also um you know how's
your response to
uh cold temperatures how's your response
to heat why is that part of fitness why
would someone who says i do fitness i've
got a fitness plan do you do hot and
cold exposure no i don't okay
what would you say to someone who's the
same way that your body has a
physiological adaptation you know a
hermetic stress we were talking on my
podcast before this about hermetic
stressors in our lives the same way that
you'd have that to develop
muscle cells to be able to be stronger
in a specific position as a product of
going through you know a bicep curl or
dead lift or whatever you're doing
your body has a similar physiologic
response to being exposed to cold
temperatures as a similar physiological
response to being exposed to heat has a
similar physiological response to being
exposed to altitude you know and so your
body is continually changing and this is
the thing that we that we started off
with a hundred percent of the time you
were under a state of construction and
all your body
knows
is environmental stimuli
you know so you have this amazing
opportunity to through exposure therapy
it just
you can start to make yourself be
stronger or
weaker you know so if you don't expose
your body to enough exposure
in the form of heat in the form of cold
in the form of heat in the form of some
type of hermetic stressor
then the body will start to atrophy
because it's inherently incredibly lazy
and that laziness it's it's it's like
one of the key features in our capacity
is to survive
what would you say
let's talk about some physical practices
for a bit yeah what are some of the
physical practices that you think i know
that you're big into groundedness and
getting hips below knees that's one of
them yeah it's a thing what about that
and some of the other physical practices
that you think people should just play
around with a little bit more when
they're in the gym the sense of play
itself is also another part of what i've
noticed in the sessions i've done with
you yeah uh is is a rarity so
let's talk about that yeah so
we
all human beings are riding on millennia
of spending time with our hips below our
knees spending time moving along you
know not necessarily like crawling along
the ground although that's a part of
your your developmental patterns and
depending upon your belief system
evolution that was probably a thing as
well and you're probably swinging
through trees if you believe in
evolution as well you're an arboreal
creature and
uh you know and then that transition to
being a bipedal
mammal cruising along the land um you
know but that's a lot of that's kind of
it could change depending upon you know
what you think so it's it's all
hypothetical like exactly where we came
from um but
getting down on the ground if you just
look at like present day thoughts on
evolution aside look at any child
the way that a child navigates their own
physiology and their own construction of
themselves is they will
squat they will sit you know in like
kind of like a cross-legged position
maybe a straddle position maybe at some
point they'll start to kneel
and so they're spending a lot of time in
that low position and that's what you
see as well looking at hunter-gatherer
tribes specifically the the hatsa people
in northern tanzania is where there's
been research about this
from the university of
southern california specifically is
where this came out of
researchers went out there
and measured the amount of time that
lots of people were spending in resting
positions because the big idea is like
you know we're like this culture of
sedentarism it's killing us it's causing
all of our issues and metabolic disease
and depression
but if you look at hunter-gatherer
tribes hatsa specifically
what you'll see as they spend about 9.82
hours was the averages that they
gathered in resting positions so
right now we're in a resting position
the difference is we're up on chairs you
know so we're forming our body into a
certain way in this position
hunter-gatherer tribes hatsa
specifically would be in kneeling
positions for a good chunk of the day
they'll be in squatting positions for a
good chunk of the day they'll be in you
know essentially all the same positions
you see your child in
and when you're in those positions uh
one it's just it's helpful with
circulating blood circulating lymph you
know like cankles are unattractive but
they're also incredibly unhealthy it's
an indication it's like oh we're in
trouble you know and so
what that does outside of just being you
know making you feel energetically
lighter you know and and more attractive
because you don't have like big thick
ankles
you're setting yourself up
to stay athletic all the way through
your life
and so when you start to limit range of
motion the ankles limit range of motion
in the hips
that affects your gait pattern the way
that you walk the way that you move
throughout the world
also
an elderly needing assisted living the
number one leading reason for that is
they've you know they've fallen flat
can't get up yeah so fall risk is this
massive thing that's completely specific
to westernized culture abandoning the
ground
it's like unbelievable when you think
about it like if you really give that a
moment of the amount of sovereignty
that's been lost and the amount of you
know time and money and energy and worry
and
it's like all of that is wrapped in
is wrapped up in us literally making an
unconscious
move
away from where we came from which is
just naturally
resting in those positions throughout
the day so what would be the
prescription let's say that someone
listens and they go okay yeah that that
sounds good i want to get rid of my
cancels i don't want to
falling and hurting myself when i'm 70
years old
what's a good way that someone can
integrate these practices into their day
so just changing your environment you
know so
have you done one with bruce lipton no
okay i think we've talked about him i
did a podcast with bruce lipton
a year and a half ago or so he's you
know big has been massive in championing
the concept of of epigenetics you know
and how our environment
changes our genetic outcome
and one of the things that he mentioned
to me was
when he was studying cells in in petri
dishes if he wanted to change something
about the cell he wouldn't do anything
specifically to the cell itself it would
be changing the culture that the cell
exists in
you know so within your own body if
you're just focusing
intrinsically on what's happening inside
the body itself that's a great start it
might get you somewhere but until you
actually change the environment that's
forming the body and and the mind and
you know your your perception itself and
all that to to fit that mold you're just
going to keep falling back into the same
position you know so you can do all the
the calf raises or all the you know the
couch stretches or all the different
kind of therapeutic rehab prehab
exercises you want
but
what got you into that position in the
first place you know and so the first
place that i would start is saying like
okay like just create a space in your
home it could be in front of the couch
you know get yourself like a comfortable
rug so it's inviting to get down to
you could put like self-care tools in
your house have like a foam roller lying
around or get one of those like
percussor guns or you know a softball to
kind of do some myofascial release stuff
on
get some moroccan poofs you know or like
floor cushions so suddenly
the culture that your cell is inhabiting
itself within
uh is shifted to invite the cell to
create change in itself just with these
like really basic visual cues
you see you walk into a space with a a
pull-up bar hanging through some doorway
just
naturally
you will have the urge to
your arms like suddenly levitate over
your head you're like i'm on the bar
like
how did that it's like it's magic the
bar is there hands on the bar yeah i
didn't have to
give you any reps or sets or tell you
got and that's the element of of play
you know so if we can start to make the
the movement landscape you know the
environment that we inhabit ourselves in
suddenly it's like we become moved by
the environment
right so when you walk outside if it's
kind of cold
and you say you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna do a little little cold
thermogenesis here i'm not going to put
like all of the layers on you know you
go out there and you get moved by
the cold suddenly you know you have this
herpetion and your hair kind of sticks
up and your body activates its own
insulation system by causing your hair
to raise up it's like a it's like a it's
like a down sleeping bag on top of your
body like
whoa
it's pretty cool that we have that
capacity we just need to place ourselves
into the environmental conditions in
order for our body to show up
but inherently your body wants to show
up
it's just we have done such a tremendous
job at outsourcing our body's necessity
to show up to you know to machine or to
amazon
nothing wrong with that it's actually
brilliant it's like it's it's freaking
amazing that that the human mind has
been able to outsource
almost everything to the point that you
can lay on a couch press buttons on your
phone
and have food delivered to your face
have sex delivered to your face
like it's pretty freaking impressive
like i'm not mad at it
you know i'm really just like in awe
like like whoa
starting from like whacking
rocks together to create fire
however sex in the face just sex in the
face off of your blue lit screen like
good effort good effort
and
um those parts that we've outsourced
not only is it
work but but work is therapeutic
you know and so
we can experience that or or witness
that in the physical body in your
biology
but you can also experience that just in
your day-to-day life and in my podcast
before this we were talking about
purpose
you know and like the pressure to have
purpose
you know and when a person feels like
they are living a an hour on purpose or
a day on purpose or a life on purpose
it's gratifying
you know and usually what that is it's
like you did work yeah you know you you
were here and you moved yourself to
there you're like
i feel better i did a thing i did a
thing yeah i am this is something
increasingly that i've realized is an
important
an important
consideration when doing any sort of
practice and especially since we've been
out here mean you have spent a lot of
time at kuya which is a hot and cold
exposure place next door uh but even
training as well that if you do a
training session or any sort of physical
practice the best judge of whether or
not it was right for you is whether you
feel good afterward or not yeah do i
feel good right after i've completed
this
because if i don't then what why why am
i doing it we go out of next door having
done three rounds of 20 minutes hot
three minutes cold ish something like
that on average
and i feel on top of the world like i
feel
phenomenal
like the the best post-sex glow without
having to find someone else to do it
with isn't that great
outstanding
like and that's just you haven't you
haven't put anything in your body i
haven't taken anything this is
completely internally generated yeah
from doing that and then the same with
some of the sessions of training you
know
i came up with this thing called the
mano pause right which was the toward
the end of their 20s
i saw a lot of guys myself included
having trained doing
like bro split lifting for a decade
maybe because we wanted to get big and
be attractive to girls or whatever
and then you'd realize uh get out of
breath going up a set of stairs and i
can't touch my toes anymore and i'm
pretty sure that my body is meant to do
more than just bicep curls and you start
to revert back to other modes of
training so maybe you do brazilian jiu
jitsu or
thai boxing or
yoga or crossfit or functional fitness
or [ __ ] running or athletics whatever
right um
and i found that my satisfaction
after doing those sorts of sessions was
so much higher
so much higher after doing that kind of
a workout and
i
it just made me think how many people
are doing a training modality that they
really genuinely don't enjoy and that
the body is telling them that they don't
enjoy but that they just stick at it
because and this is probably correct
that something is better than nothing
but that if the end goal of your fitness
is to make you be like a happier
healthier stronger human being then
you can just use how do i feel post
workout as a pretty good judge of
whether or not my training modality at
the moment is working yep well it's like
we were talking about before as well
it's like you don't know what you don't
know
you know so if you are have been you
know whatever workout dogma or regimen
you've subscribed to over the years
you kind of have you're just like
getting work in just like getting it
done
um that's great i'd rather someone have
oh thanks you turned my gain up
yeah it's a little low and a little bit
quiet it's fine damn i was noticing that
the whole time um
yeah so
some work
is better than no work
but
you can paint yourself into a corner
with your work that eventually you might
have to
reverse engineer
to get yourself out of that corner
so so say
ronnie coleman would be a great example
of this you know
have you watched any ronnie coleman
stuff kind of sad to see him now yeah
super sweet guy
like really like beautiful heart i don't
know personally but you know i i spend
i've spent enough hours watching like
yep yeah exactly i'm like he's like a
sweetie
you know but he would be a great example
you know if he's he's
he did it you know he like like goal
arrived at you know smashed smashed the
goal the only thing that he ever
regretted in his entire bodybuilding
career was not doing 800 for five right
he did it for two and he was adamant
that he could have back squatted 800 for
five instead right like i knew i had
another three in me yeah ronnie you
you're bed band with 75 steel screws in
your spine and you live on the highest
dose of painkillers that is legally
allowed and your one regret is that you
didn't do 800 for five instead of eight
hundred to two yep so for him he won
like it ultimately it's all perception
and filters and you know how we it's
like what are your goals so i think the
first thing for someone is to to have a
definitive goal of what it is that you
where do you want to arrive and i i
think it would it would behoove people
to
draw beyond just where do i want to
arrive aesthetically but also coming
from a place of feel
you know so how do you want to feel in
one week one year
you know
30 years
you know what what are what are the
values that are actually in fact the
most important for you you know and i
think if people are a lot of people are
honest or really feel into that question
you probably want to you know be feel
you don't want to feel a bunch of pain
you know you want to feel light in your
body you want to feel flexible in your
body you want to feel maybe adaptable
you want to feel strong you want to feel
confident you want to be able to play
with your kids or your grandkids or be
able to get down and pick up a dog
like those things
matter you know so i would i would think
about how do we start to reverse
engineer a program to make sure that we
have some of those staples ingrained
into the system and what that's going to
look like
is you're probably going to be walking
you're probably maybe going to be like
lunging you know keeping that some that
spaciousness open and around the ankles
and around the hips
keeping flexibility and adaptability
throughout the spine you know when the
spine is is
impinged
or
impinges a fine word for it or off
neutral be another way of of saying
it feels unstable it feels unsafe it
doesn't trust you to be strong
and so if you're moving through the
world and say like a you know like a
forward head posture type position or
your shoulders are collapsed forward or
you have
excessive extension in the lower back
and the lumbar spine
that's sending the signal to your
central nervous system that it's not
safe to go you know deliver power
through this system yep just switches it
off it just switches it off
super amazing like you're like thank you
because i'd much rather
you i have some type of
parent figure
for my
the the function of my nervous system
yeah because i'm not responsible enough
for that
it's the same the same thing with
breathing and same thing with you know
cardiac function the same thing with
lymphatic function you're not
responsible enough to govern all of
these systems
so you have to have the quality control
manager that oversees it all yeah so if
you're wondering why
maybe you feel stiff chronically or
maybe you feel like man i've like
reached this plateau and i just can't go
beyond it there could be a conversation
around joint balance or centration
concentration just being a 50 cent word
for for balance really you know having
maximum range
having joints oriented so that i have
matched maximum capacity to move in all
directions
that's athleticism that's adaptability
if my joints are pinned up to you know
the edge they're on like the precipice
of disaster if i go any further in this
one direction but then i have excessive
mobility in the other direction then
inevitably your body because it loves
you it's going to put you into bracing
and tension
now all of a sudden an analogy for that
would be like it's like you left your
house with the with the lights on yeah
so now throughout the day your lights
are just oh you got the air conditioner
running you got the lights on
vacuum cleaner just
just just vacuuming nothing because your
body's like you're like
it's holding that it's it's holding
itself together because ultimately
it's it's received the message that if
it lets go
um that would be unsafe there's a good
story that stu mcgill uses about
one of the world's strongest man
events from a few years ago
and i want to say it was
it was either a they were back squatting
a car
or they were overhead pressing like axle
pressing a car
and uh he said if you watch the event
you can see the rep before the guy is
about to fail
it must have been it was back squatting
you can see the rep before he fails
every single person and this is true you
can go back and check it every single
person when they reset from the
penultimate set uh right before they
fail all of them take a big breath in
and just shift their hips a tiny little
bit yeah he's like that is the spine
saying
buddy you've got nothing left in the tub
done yep so i'm gonna
kill the power yep
and then when they go to power out at
the bottom maybe their legs have got
something in it but the spines decided
to pull the the kill chord yeah and
there's just nothing left so let's say
let's say that somebody that that's
listening does a lot of training and
they think right okay this sounds this
sounds great like i i need to be
functional i should move in a more
holistic manner i like the idea of
creating an environment in my house that
kind of engenders a
parasympathetic
very calm
self-love self-work kind of environment
um what else
can i do like give me some practices
give me some takeaways sure that i can
do to encourage a more holistic aligned
body protocol yeah well so
two of the things we mentioned is just
making orienting your space so that you
just get your damn hips below the height
of your
your knees every now and again like just
get yourself down there so that's in
that sort of upright squatting position
another note
or anything you do that sometimes
leaning up against a wall so someone
could just get down off the couch and
then just lean up against the couch with
in that bottom of the squat position
yeah absolutely yeah just be it and then
so a part of that as well as as per
mentioned before like engendering a bit
more of this this nature of play
into your life you know inviting that
into even inviting that into
conversations you know not being so damn
stuffy and serious you know the way that
we communicate to each other if you look
at and this is going out of like well
this is kind of kind of
practices that are in the book or at
least conversations or philosophies of
the book
you know different cultures
gesticulate they use their hand gestures
or facial expressions more or less than
others you know so you go to italy
suddenly it's like you're out here and
then here and here you look like ah
somebody grabs you by the shirt like
pulls you in
you know it's like that's just how we
communicate like that's i'm just
expressing you know
and you maybe go someplace else maybe
like i don't know you know i don't know
some place in the united states or maybe
like a muslim culture be different like
uh like a buddhist culture is gonna be
different than a you know each place has
their movement signature
and there is there are
there are implications and repercussions
of of each of these
you know and it's like the what are they
what do they call it the french paradox
it's like how are these damn french
people eating all these baguettes
and they're still like pretty darn
healthy how is it how is it that they
managed to eat all these baguettes and
they're healthy i think there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of
elements in that i think community is
the main one i think people run on
community we run on purpose we run on
community we run on the sensation that
uh i've got your back you've got my back
you know and i think that when that when
we have that sensation of of safety
again safety central nervous system
neutral spine
right when we come into that place of
feeling safe with my community it allows
me at a neuro muscular cellular like all
the way down into ourselves level
uh to be able to relax to be able to
breathe to be able to you know have that
so i think the french paradox has a lot
to do with people just getting out and
eating together and drinking together
and smoking cigarettes and
you know whatever brings people together
like i would take a a smoker ideally of
like some organic cigarettes that are
just mostly exclusively tobacco and not
a bunch of chemicals uh that gets them
to go outside and take a walk and
connect and like you know have a
shoulder to lean on and get some natural
sunlight exposure to their eyeballs and
maybe get a little cold thermogenesis or
maybe a little heat
and you know they have their vice
quotations
i would take that person
over
the
um orthorexic person what's that
orthorex is a person that's like has an
unhealthy obsession with health okay
i take that person any day for to be on
my kickball team to be on my you know my
my business
who's obsessed with health but spends
all of their time on their own staring
at the screen and never getting the hips
below their knees and doesn't have a
culture and doesn't have community and
doesn't have support structure yeah so
again i'm not advising that people take
up tobacco um but if you look at that
tobacco what is it the tobacco in the
last conversation we were talking about
dogs you're moved by your dog
dog comes into the room you don't just
sit there aimlessly you know kind of
like monk like
staring forward you react and engage
with the dog
so suddenly your facial patterns change
and suddenly your voice tonality might
change
you know there's a stephen stephen
porges he's a guy that that
came up with the concept of polyvagal
theory calls it that your voice porosity
so when we're communicating we're
literally tuning each other's nervous
systems based off of the tone of our
voices
you know so
there's a professor from a
professor of psychology in the 60s
called albert moravian i know i'm
jumping around a little bit but it's
going to maybe wind back to something
came up with a thing called the 55 38 7
principle and what that suggests
is 55 of our communication comes from
body language and then 38 is coming from
the tone of our voice and then there's
the last little seven percent is like
the actual words that we're conveying
so if there's incongruence between what
the body is saying
and the words
with at least i mean i think it's i mean
unless you're a complete
dummy i think it's higher than 93
percent but you're gonna trust
the body 93 of the time
you know so
the cigarette
not condoning cigarettes you know but it
it it moves the person
say i got the cigarette okay we can't
smoke inside i'm walking outside ah dog
comes into the room you know if you're
like a
you know a large you know an overweight
person that's stuck in your house
staring at tv all day long stressing out
about the computer
one of the healthiest things you could
probably do for yourself is just start
by getting a dog all right [ __ ] dog
man get a dog
you're doing all this stuff you know
you're getting your protein shakes and
you got your creatine you got your
glutamine you know you got the trainer
that you go see three times a week and
you know
none of them are going to create the
difference that would manifest in your
life by having that just having that
accountability in their relationship
with that dog and that's you know not
even it's excluding all of the the
immune benefits of a dog bringing
retirement as well bringing nature into
the house
what about
a little bit of a pivot what about sex
what about relationships
with the work that you've done have you
seen
a
what dysfunctions do you see with
regards to people and their
relationship to sex and to their own
body and to the way that they judge
other people's bodies as well
well definitely not my field of depth um
but i think it's very
an interesting conversation that is a
physical conversation around that not
that sex isn't physical
but more like anatomical would be
the way that shame manifests in the body
you know so growing up in a culture that
doesn't have
maybe full
ease
around
sex you know or menstruation or having a
penis or having an anus or all of these
things like oh like
everyone gets a little uncomfortable if
you say anus
is like whoa
pull it back
it was like yeah you got one i got one
like i took a [ __ ] four hours ago you
know but it's like to to to talk about
that or to think about that it's like oh
my god it's like
what if i didn't take a [ __ ] today
it would be dramatically what if i
didn't take a [ __ ] for a week
it would be like
my whole life would be in shambles
you know and so i think sex is one of
those things it's like our nether
regions
you know that part of our body it's it's
we're not really
um
inculcated for the most part at least i
wasn't uh into a culture that has a lot
of acceptance
of those spaces
you know in the way that shame manifests
in the body just look at it physically
if you're ashamed if you're embarrassed
you know without getting metaphysical
and you know saying like oh shame
there's deep tension in the perennium
and the cells and the root chakra or any
kind of just kind of
random random bits
feel in your body
what does shame feel like
you know like for for you if you
suddenly tightness it's like it's sort
of the stiffness and the tightness in
the in the stomach in the head yeah or
maybe a collapse could be a flavor
falling forward yeah right you know what
does
um
pride what does strength feel like what
does sadness feel like you know the
whole gamut of emotions you know that's
that's um sir william james who's he's
like
widely known as the the father of modern
psychology he
was one of the the preeminent leaders in
uh the conversation of not just a
top-down physiology being like the mind
affects the body you know so we see a
bear
i'm scared
i run you know and i respond
we could just as easily flip that around
and go bottom up and say
i see a bear
i have a physiological response it moves
my body into this state that we
deem to be fear
and that perpetuates the feeling and the
emotion and then that winds back and
it's this ping pong boom
feedback system back and forth mind body
mind body mind body it doesn't matter
where it starts or where it ends like
the chicken or the egg question it's
like both whatever really doesn't matter
they're inextricably tied
so if we grow up in a culture
that
inherently there's a
maybe it's not overt shame but maybe
just like shadow
you know or blank spots like there's
some pages in our
physiology in our anatomy that aren't as
well filled out
you know so uh there's a term you ever
heard the term homunculus no homunculus
means little man
and essentially it's like well just flip
my my uh toothpick here uh homunculus
means little man it's it's essentially
like the way that it's like the
neurological real estate that our body
has to
sensation
uh or
of how different appendages experience
sensation the amount of real estate
that's offered to that sensory reception
in those various different parts in the
body you know and so your fingers will
have in this little man image it's like
literally
you could we could you could look it up
it's a really interesting thing to see
they've got like really big lips you
know and they've got like really big
hands and you know pretty reasonably
sized gentles actually
it's got a piece yeah got a piece you
got it you got a piece on them
you know so that distribution of sensory
awareness can change depending upon a
person's
uh life experience
you know so there's some places in the
body that for some people it might
literally be like a shadow place like
you could
numb that space
out you know some people don't have a
lot of sensation in certain parts of
their body like maybe like their back
you know you could
rub a you know a
paper clip or a feather or something in
certain parts of the body it's like no
i've literally shut that part down
and then it becomes this whole process
of re-engaging and re-integrating that
that aspect of yourself and do you think
symbolically that can happen with
regards to shame around sex and our
bodies
not just in terms of how we perceive
them physiologically if we can touch
them and if we can get feedback but how
we
see them symbolically in our minds i
think so
what do you think
yeah certainly man i mean
it's definitely since being out here in
austin [ __ ] like people here have got
a very
some people here got a very liberal very
open
uh relationship to sex and sexual
practices and talking about sex
far more i don't know whether it's a
british thing maybe it is a little bit
but
far more than i've been used to in the
uk and i'd say i'm you know
relatively open about
being happy to talk about things that
have gone well or badly or that i'd like
or don't like during sex but [ __ ] out
here is a
another level i don't know whether
that's just because you talk about a
thing a lot doesn't mean that you have a
healthy relationship with it oh yeah but
i mean
this not being able to talk about it at
all probably isn't a sign of a good
relationship with it also not yeah so
yeah it's been
it's been interesting being out here um
it's the flexibility again it comes back
to adaptability and flexibility if
you're if something makes you
uncomfortable if i say a word you know
any of the words i said previously and
you go oh yeah a little bit yeah just a
little bit you're like ah cool
that's a place that there is if you
choose to take it an opportunity
probably for you to uncover some
um you know internal impingement
you don't need to address it but it's
it's there if someone pisses you off you
know if someone makes you feel away it's
probably some reflection back into some
insecurity within yourself or else there
wouldn't be a charge around it
what are you working on at the moment
personally like what what's the next
2022 if you were to look back at the end
of 2022 and consider it a success
what would have been a
a development that you would have
gone through
well
i mean something that we've talked about
previously is i have a a bit of a
tendency of
in i don't know if i enjoy it but
i have a proclivity towards chasing
you know and that was kind of something
that we've been talking about in
relation to like to
female relationships and something that
i'm observing in myself you know when
something is unavailable it becomes
highly prized
and
when the availability begins there
sometimes i i not sometimes i i can
completely notice
[Music]
the opportunity to work with that for me
is is
resistance around that or a disinterest
uh kind of like a like an avoidant type
pattern
you know and so for me it's like aha
okay well the
there's there's the work
you know so now it's it's my
the onus is on on me alone to engage
with it
um or to go to the next and
re-perpetuate patterns
you know so that for me it's like
looking in and really being honest with
what that is
what do you think it is
likely
my story for that which i think that's
another thing to be cautious of is being
attached to her stories yeah over
rationalizing your over narrative naruto
narratizing whatever it is that you're
supposed to do yeah
and that's when things things that kind
of trump our stories like maybe some
type of you know breath work ceremony
thing or some life event that was
dragged outside of the narrative that
you've tried to wrap around and
rationalize a story with yeah that's an
interesting one whatever maybe suddenly
you're like oh okay story
out you know story on the side yes now
here's like god reality yeah like
there's like a there's like the higher
purview comes in it's like
okay we don't need words right now
little aaron
this is we're just on truth
you know and i think that those moments
happen when they happen um but
for me the narrative that i
have that i think probably has some
level of sense to it is i think that my
mother
was who i did i've done actually a full
like i don't know like 90 minute podcast
with her and i was like i think it's a i
know it's the only podcast that i've
ever like really properly broke down
wept
in a couple times um
and uh
she had a background of
some level of abuse i'm not sure if i
shared in the podcast or not so i don't
know if it's appropriate to share but
she learned that it's not appropriate
to not be okay
you know so kind of like good vibes only
type thing which is incredibly dangerous
because then you lack decompression you
know so suddenly you
pin it up you know any of those
sensations that would be deemed
unfavorable it's just like okay those
don't go out they go in
and now they just sit and fester and
kind of ferment
and so getting the signal that
everything needs to be okay everything
needs to like be alrighty
um i think that there was a certain
level of
she was very caring very sweet
you know always made me sandwiches and
always like had my back
but i think there was a certain
emotional
vulnerability that was
challenging for her to access and i
think i subconsciously picked that up
and so when there is emotional
vulnerability specifically with a female
it's it's scary to me you know and so
i'm like oh this is like a lot
you know and so within that i think i've
adapted and a lot of people have have
done this
you know i've adapted to be able to
create rapport with with quickness
you know so what i've
because of a general avoidance of depth
i've
reintroduced that bandwidth into like
superficial
and so
i think you have
have this as well probably for different
reasons um but an ability to connect
with
new people
and find common ground pretty quick uh
and you always feel i think is maybe
part of a defense mechanism yeah for
sure that's interesting yeah definitely
[ __ ] that's interesting and then when it
goes to a certain level i'm like okay
too far too far yeah yeah yeah but we're
like you know like fast bros or fast you
know yep bro and bro and sister like
real fast and then there's a certain
level because that that part's so well
developed there's a certain level that
it's kind of like okay and as soon as
you're outside it's that safety
position yeah i am hopefully that wasn't
too much information about mine no not
at all i think it's [ __ ] interesting
man like it's really interesting to
think that you could compensate for a
fear of depth or a hesitation around
depth by
over selling on rapport
or overselling on uh immediate
connection and that makes a lot of sense
um i it doesn't resonate with me
personally but i can absolutely see how
it would happen
um
so getting through that trying to get
yourself past the slightly more i guess
juvenile
areas of
of the avoidant attachment
side i mean i have a ton of friends and
i think that this is
i'd be very interested to find out
how this relates to people that are
whatever high agency or high achieving
guys um a lot of my buddies that
are
high achievers also have that attachment
style sure which is funny because
people are prepared to
uh
push their limits
in so many places you know
if we needed to do a a
24-hour workout or a you know an
unbelievable sauna and cold session or
whatever like pick what pick whatever
challenge it is that you want to do
and yet there are these sort of deep
dark holes that
sometimes don't get uncovered quite so
easily maybe they're a little bit more
difficult to see what's going on
maybe they're just
an area of the territory that we can't
get rid of
as simply but it is strange that there's
nothing to get rid of okay to deal with
i know that you've heard yourself
probably as you're saying that yeah um
to to to
come into
healthier relationships
and healthy just means whole that's like
the original meaning of health
does it yeah okay yeah so whole coming
back to the body integrated
so if i
disconnect the parts
you know i got my bicep brachialis and i
got my triceps and i got the you know
the the multiple heads of the quads and
i got you know really
specifically
breaking down those individual
points
um that can potentially lead to a a
disintegration of the whole body working
together
and then that creates you know cacophony
but there's something about the fact
that a lot of my friends that can push
themselves in many other areas
still have as their
one of the final bastions of challenge
is their avoidant attachment oh yeah
it's the big one you think that's the
whatever the achilles heel
it's not the mirrors got their own thing
you know but that's i think relationship
is one of
the
ultimate reflections upon yourself
you know getting into deeper
awareness or more authentic awareness
with your relationship to your parents
and i think a lot of it comes back to
that you're like okay interesting you
know and so if you do
allow if you you know if you you do play
the game you actually say like cool like
all right pushing chips in you know and
actually be there for it
um
yeah i mean if if you really how many
people really want to look at themselves
like i think we all say that we do but i
think the only reason to be afraid of a
psychedelic trip or maybe a relationship
or you know psychedelics are another
really good example of that like i think
a bad trip most people that i've talked
to they've had bad trips like i've had
things that i've deemed like oh that
felt pretty like bad
um it was just an exposure to some
aspect of my myself from my orientation
to the world that i was uncomfortable
with and i didn't want to look at and i
was in that time in that that moment i
was kind of almost felt like forced to
be in that
that space to say like okay here you are
here's your relationship with you know
fill in the blank whatever the thing is
um and then wanting to get out
but
the
the way
to get to the other side of that into
you know finding like healing and ease
and you know all of that holism health
um is through it
and it's you can either you know wrestle
the relationship
or wrestle the mushroom or wrestle you
know whatever which you will not win
i've tried
i can guaran i can guarantee it with
with with the mushroom you will not win
the analogy that i used was it's like
being sat on a firework and as you try
to steer it to the left or the right it
goes
yeah and just makes it only makes it
worse yeah it only gets bigger it wasn't
a good strategy for you know it's like
the what's that what's this what's the
the gal with the snakeheads you chop off
the snakeheads
is that one she's got like tons of
snakeheads
yes the hydra yeah it's the hydra
you know so
ultimately i'm trying to you know
hopefully not getting like excessively
metaphysical or esoteric but you know
ultimately i think a a relationship
is an opportunity um you know just like
i said like a like you know the mushroom
thing you know surrender in my
experience surrender has been
um
the ticket
to
ease you know like like not fighting you
know in that moment it's like cool
whatever the thing is uh you don't need
to fight
and
it's interesting have you had that
experience with yourself at all
wrestling wrestling a thing and instead
of fighting the thing coming to a place
of just like
you know what take me
yeah i mean
my first ever mushroom trip was
precisely this and i just refused to let
go yeah so for whatever five hours i
just wrangled everything and just kept
kept that puppy kind of as under as much
control as i could which just made for a
very very uncomfortable that's what
terence mckinney said the only thing you
can do the only mistake you can make
with with psychedelics is not taking
enough
well that was five grams for my first
ever time and even with that i was like
i'm i'm gonna [ __ ] wrap you up in a
big big prison and see if i can hold on
yeah and i'm pretty much managed to
which is just like looking back but but
then you're not you're not exactly super
lucid at the time uh
yeah i don't know man i i certainly
resonate with when you when you think
about being in the body right and you
notice that you've been sat in a meeting
or in a situation with someone and
you've been tense and then you kind of
check in with yourself and you
and everything just eases up a little
bit or you open your gaze the best cue
that i've learned about this i learned
this this year uh from an embodiment
coach is about um just using the
peripherals of your vision yeah so just
using that open gaze and man i love that
cue so much it just reminds me that look
there's so much more going on you do not
need to focus just there you can have
all of this beautiful vision outside of
you yeah um there's a whole chapter in
the align method book about that all
right tell me andrew andrew huberman who
he's you know popularized a lot of these
conversation last reason he
thankfully um edited
through the whole thing for me and kind
of you know like pointed me in the right
direction that and i've been just i owe
so much to his mind and his
his research
but yeah i mean the way that you use
your eyes your your eyes are continuous
with your central nervous system you
know so
similarly this is one of the things i
was gonna eventually likely get to in
relation to environmental conditions
changing the visual environment isn't
just adding visual cues that cause you
to do what would look like
mobility or exercise it's also changing
the visual environment in the sense of
like you know open some windows
ideally get full spectrum light into
your eyeballs you know so it's not just
when you're when you're looking at light
through windows it's going to be
blocking some percentage of the either
uva or uvb spectrum out
and being able to
relax your eyes and awareness that when
i am in that panoramic like
i'm just taking it all in
that that lens of perception it's
sending
a signal into the rest of your
physiology which is probably an anchored
pattern for again millennia back like
you know generations generation like
forever
that when you are just taking it all in
just spacing out
probably almost never in history have
you just spaced it out and taken it all
in and been under attack
right
and so
it's a similar thing talk and then when
you're myopically focused in suddenly
okay cool we're taking it all in we're
just gathering information about the
whole or maybe not gather information
screw that we're just
ah there's basking in the moment we're
fed you know we've hunted
and then suddenly there is a threat what
do your eyes do
you know it all focuses in on that
single point i've been thinking about
this to do with smartphones oh of course
yeah so much about it you're looking
down and you're looking down and to the
right you know so you're looking down or
you know if you're lefty you know which
would be more rare but you're looking
down into a specific direction so your
eyes act like reins to your
neuromuscular system so you can do this
you know put your your fingertips back
the bottom of your skull it's called the
suboccipital ridge and just look up
and down
and you'll feel those muscles
called suboxone muscles engaging right
yeah so you're funny so same thing in in
um it was in chimpanzees this has been
researched there
the the cochlea in their ear will change
direction with the eyes
so when you are
looking to the right to to some
potential threat or whatever the thing
is
literally even their their auditory
system so their hearing opens up as
their eyes move almost it will it will
orient towards
that thing no way which is kind of an
interesting thing for people that are
like you know into jiu jitsu and
wrestling have like cauliflower here i
wonder how that affects affects things
but
yeah man your visual system is so deeply
tied into your sense of
uh either you know alertness or
um you know executive function get or
done or relax digest rest
uh you know so that's in in
the book in the align method the the
really
the intention of it isn't so much to
have like
a step-by-step
method
it's more
uh you know a philosophy to reorient the
way that a person engages with their
body in any situation
you know so
from the victor frankel yes logotherapy
manchester meaning
uh one of the things that he said
that i align with is uh that he said
he's more like an optometrist than you
know like a psycholo psychologist you
know so he's just he's just working with
people's perception
of the world you know the way that they
process information their filter
you know and so i think that that's a
really valuable approach to one's
fitness you know it's fitness isn't a
thing that i do fitness is a thing that
i am you know so all the time throughout
every day they're all a bunch of
opportunities if you have the education
on how to engage with those
opportunities you know so you're just
filled with these fun layer fun levers
all over your body so your eyes they
will change the way that your your
mental emotional state based off of the
way that you use them if you have that
information you can leverage it same
thing with your auditory environment
same thing with your you know the sense
of touch
certain sensations or textures will make
you feel one way certain sensations of
texture make you feel another way
your visual environment an interesting
thing that
you have to fact chest fact check this
one but i heard uh with real estate if
you're selling a place and you have like
like pointy plants out front that sends
an indication to potential buyers to
stay away no way
i mean you've got to look it up there's
a there's a whole field of state you'd
probably appreciate called embodied
cognition
body cognition essentially is is the way
that
um we
we think and feel uh based off of our
our physical experience you know so i'm
sure you've heard of like the clipboard
studies you know where if you give
somebody your resume and it's on like a
big thick beefcake clipboard they're
like oh [ __ ] yeah like this guy's he
really knows you know he's he's serious
you know he's stable he's supported
i like this guy
right if you and so that's that tactile
experience of like man this guy feels
like oh i could trust him
all right same thing with you know
people that are tend to be taller or you
know lower voices is something we were
talking about before it's like
there's something trustworthy about that
like it feels like it feels powerful
you're like they might just be a tall
[ __ ]
like it doesn't necessarily mean
anything
but the way that we cognate that or the
our embodied experience of that is like
oh yeah i trust it
you know same thing with if we're we
have a cold beverage and someone goes
into a job interview or a warm beverage
right now we had icy you know whatever
some some lemonades or something like
that but like icy cups
based off of research we would perceive
this experience as being a little bit
more that's why i was noticing the
temperature of the room we
perceived this experience as being a
little bit kind of like more closed a
little bit colder if you give me like a
hot cocoa and it's warm and we got a
fire going in the background and we can
hear the crackling of the fire suddenly
that's changing my perception to say
like
wow man i just feel so safe here there's
something about you chris that makes me
feel safe
it's like is it me or is it just the
environment that we're having this
mutual experience
shit's crazy man
this more holistic view of the body
overall and of fitness
is something that
i don't know maybe to you and maybe the
people that you're speaking to it's kind
of uh
how do you say
obvious or
it makes a complete amount of sense but
to me this is like an entire new world
like it looks great
a whole new world it makes sense though
it's simple well the human system the
human system is is one thing altogether
it's broken up into component parts but
working on each component part without
taking into account all of the other
things doesn't really seem to make sense
and
some of the things that you've mentioned
to me since we've been hanging out to do
with
um
you can tell a lot about a person's
personality by the way that they move
when they walk into a sauna or a
restaurant or to sit down at a date or
the way that they hold themselves or the
way that their gesture or whatever right
like
that why why is that the case if it
wasn't that we were such a global system
where our cognition and our physicality
and our emotions and our social status
and our confidence and our blah blah
if it wasn't the case that all of those
were together
why would it be
that from something i can
induce
how somebody is in a completely
unrelated area so to speak yeah it's not
it's the one closed system yeah um so
you've got a
special revised
paperback edition you have the align
method coming out where can people get
that
uh
yeah i hopefully your bookstore would be
great that would be very aligned
method-esque of you to take a walk
outside uh ideally remove sunglasses you
know get full spectrum light there's a
lot of british people listening they
haven't done sunglasses in there yeah
right exactly i mean that's it i mean it
tunes your your neurochemistry you know
that that light penetrating your
eyeballs a reason that i know what that
was a cue to wrap up so don't say don't
spout more
more factoids fire up fire away my
factoids we're here for the factoids
[ __ ] keep them coming
but you're uh
a big reason that that such a high
percentage of of people
are becoming myopic you know
specifically like china something like
93 percent like a really high percentage
of adolescents are becoming myopic
um
same how do you define myopic
nearsighted okay yeah we see near well
far not so easy
so one potential conversation there
would be that we're just practicing
nearsightedness all the time so those
ciliary muscles and all the muscles that
help change the shape of the lens to be
able to refract that light so it comes
into clear vision we're like well you're
only using the close ones so you're
going to have a problem with the other
ones
but a bigger part of the conversation is
is the the impact that natural sunlight
has on the the structure and the shape
and the the chemical structural makeup
of your eyeballs
so
sun it literally the exact process i
can't go through because i'm you know
that's not like my my specialty
but sun literally it changes
it it's you know it's a physical thing
it's like a nutrient you know it changes
the structure and the makeup
of
of your eyes
you know and so when you're going
outside it's not just like a
relax the eyes you know it's an
opportunity to down regulate the nervous
system or calm the freak down it's
literally it's like
you're nourishing the structure of your
eyeballs through
that exposure to the sunlight
you know so sunlight it just it's so
healing in so many capacities and i know
i didn't you know
break down exactly what's happening
within that system so
let me come back i'll go deeper in the
research of what that system is exactly
but experts
pretty much unanimously
align that sunlight it changes the
structure and the makeup of your
eyeballs and so you you need it for
healthy eyes you need it for healthy
everything
doing a morning walk here in austin
because the weather tends to be it's a
bit muggy sometimes on the morning but
maybe 50 of the days it's sunny yeah the
morning walk with sunshine is so good i
always do the walk anyway but in the uk
if i was to do it at the time i'm doing
out here it would still be dark and that
infrared light specifically in the
morning you're setting and i think a lot
of people listen to this but you know by
now they know about this
but you're setting the circadian rhythm
for the rest of the day so when you're
waking up that that light when the sun's
first coming up it's tuning your whole
neurophysiology your neurochemistry your
hormones your endocrine system to be
alert to be up you know it's like this
it's it's it's like that it's a it's a a
book end start of the day
i only learned recently that the reason
that we get a burst of energy after the
lights go out is that that would be
adaptive for our ancestors to get
themselves home
while the sun was setting hmm
that's cool i heard that so this is in
johann hari's stolen focus which is
coming out in the new year it'll be
really good i've read half of it
and he mentioned that
one of the reasons that we're struggling
to have attention at the moment is
because of a lack of sleep and the lack
of sleep is partly due to the fact that
we use blue screens at night but
what is the reason that
blue screens have such an effect on our
energy levels and our ability to fall
asleep easily
and one of the proposed reasons for this
is that
when we go from
light to dark our bodies get a kick of
energy why would that be useful well if
you're out hunting or not in your cave
or not at your camp yeah it would be
pretty good for you to just get a little
extra kick i've had that experience many
times
like camping or you know rock climbing
or something where you're out in the
woods sunset and the sun goes down
you're like
we gotta go yep and
suddenly we're running you know and you
get that that full sympathetic burst so
like we gotta get to where we're gonna
see i never thought about that
what johan's saying is that let's say
that you're using your phone or watching
netflix until you go to sleep and then
precisely at the moment when you're
about trying to get a little juice up
precisely that's really fascinating
some interesting stats around e-readers
that it doesn't seem like they have the
same sort of response yeah they're not
emitting that light i need to speak to
human about that um but i don't think
that they have the same effect the other
thing that's interesting that i wanted
to to mention in relation to eyes i just
i think is just so cool is that humans
are one of the only
mammals to have uh white sclerosis that
the white part so we can see the
orientation and the positioning of our
eyes it's called the
they call it the eye
eye coordination hypothesis i think is
the like the so that the 50 century
other people can see what we're looking
at yeah and so the the the potential
suggestion for that like like a like an
evolutionary
adaptation would be to be able to signal
to each other for hunting you know and
so you'll see this and the reason they
would suggest is you see this with with
certain dogs so like more like pack
animals
they also have that indication to be
able to see where their eyes are are
oriented
uh and then also to be able to see the
the wellness of a person you know so
that's in this is becomes interesting in
the whole you know like the the year the
lockdowns and everything it's like
we have we're pretty good senses when
someone's unwell
like
you know that's that's body language
that's voice tonality that's reading the
scleras of somebody's eyes that's you
know you go chinese medicine route and
you know see the what's the they have
like some furry stuff on their tongue or
their cracks in their tongue we have all
of these
millions or billions of bits of visual
information and all fact olfactory
information as well the way we smell
uh
suggesting whether that person is
healthy to be close to
somebody has terrible breath you're like
get the hell away from me terrible body
oh you're like please don't give me a
hug no thank you if someone's sniffling
you're like not interested
if someone's got bloodshot eyes or they
have like yellow eyes you're like i
don't know what's going on is this
hepatitis is this like
there's something going on here i would
love for you to visit a doctor
i love you
you know but
you need to go
like you got to sort this out and then
come back to the tribe
and then even if within yourself if you
are
that guy or that girl you're like okay i
need to
pull myself out of the tribe
self-regulatory i need to sort this out
you know and so our subconscious
intuition is just so [ __ ] cool
we've just learned to you know kind of
outsmart ourselves and you will never
outsmart yourself it's the same concept
of trying to put together your 640
muscles in your 360 joints you will not
be successful
but if you allow yourself to kind of
listen to that
inner wisdom
you know and the the integration of the
inner wisdom and the modern wisdom
ultimately moderate wisdom would be that
inner wisdom
um i think suddenly it's like maybe
surrendering to that which is a
surrendering term i think that's that
can be kind of funny for some people
um
but behind that uh that's i think that's
where true wisdom is
aaron alexander ladies and gentlemen
align podcast um a line method book
everything will be linked in the show
notes below any of the stuff that people
should check out
no i think that's it i mean
thanks again for making this happen i
really enjoy this has a really really
fun conversation i appreciate the way
that your mind operates and the way that
you create space for uh
other minds to to turn the way that they
do
so thank you for creating the space for
this
um yeah go check out the
aligned podcast with you i really
enjoyed that conversation
another one they could check out would
be the bruce lipton conversation they
want to go deeper into some of these
topics and then the align method book is
coming out january 11th and so they
could get it this is before that they
can pre-order it it's on amazon or you
know barnes and nobles or whatever
and
i think that's it man i appreciate you
awesome dude first of many
yeah let's keep doing it all right over
and out
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe peace